- I'm here with Emily Blunt,
give it up! (imitates buzzer)
In honor of her new movie,
A Quiet Place 2 which airs
in theaters May 28th.
It's time to play a game
called the quiet case.
♪ A quiet case, shhh. ♪
- Oh yes.
- I had never heard of that.
- [Emily] I love that.
- Its very sexy, Jessie, nice,
nice. I'm going to be singing
that all night.
- She was with the duke
just then.
just then in her head,
that's what she said. Always.
First we need hosts everybody,
so please welcome the hosts
of American Ninja warrior on NBC,
Matt Iseman and Akbar Gbaja-Biamila.
(cheering)
All right, all right.
- I like the dance moves.
- [Kelly] What's up, y'all?
- Hey we're good.
- We are so thrilled to be here.
- You're doing good? I'm ready to win.
So how does this game go?
- Well, this game is
going to be pretty good.
- So Akbar and I have eight cases here.
Inside these cases are secret items.
Now Kelly and Emily will each
take turns choosing a case.
Akbar and I will then open the case
and use the item inside of them
as quietly as possible.
- [Emily] I'm sweating,
this is so intense.
[Kelly] Okay, okay.
- First person to buzz
in and correctly guess
what the item is
[Kelly] Okay.
based just on its sound gets the point.
- Did you just do a lunge?
- Yes.
- [Akbar] And feels are
allowed in this game.
So shh, it's time to play A Quiet Case.
- I'm ready, ears are
ready, ears are ready.
- [Matt] Here it is, at TKCS,
that's Kelly Clarkson Show
for our new guests,
- Nice.
- guests go first, Emily.
- Oh.
- You choose your case.
- Six.
- I was already ready.
We're not even doing anything.
Okay, so we're not going
to be able to see it.
- Don't look over here.
- Don't you cheat Blunt.
- I'm known for it.
- [Kelly] I will not play
a game with the cheater.
- All right you guys ready?
- Did you do it?
(buzzer dings)
- We saw the light first.
Emily, you buzzed in.
- Its like a can of soda.
(correct ding) (cheers)
- Yes! Great job.
- I'm going on the wall.
- In my defense, I thought the
noise before the can of soda
was part of it.
- Me too!
You were rummaging around with something
and I was like is that pebbles?
- You have to try to figure it out.
I would've answered a can of beer.
That would have been acceptable
(laughs)
But now, Kelly its your choice.
- Okay. I am picking two.
- Okay.
- [Kelly] Oh man. Okay. Okay.
- That's a losing number.
- No it is not. No its not.
- Losing number yeah.
- Oh she's talking trash.
She's letting you know.
- Its the first number
of my favorite number.
- I see Blunt trying to
catch a secret, secret-
- I didn't, I didn't I promise.
- Okay. Are you guys ready?
- Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Okay.
- Here comes your sound.
(buzzer dings)
- Whoa! How did you know that so fast.
- A brush? (incorrect buzzer)
- [Emily] Do it again.
- Not a brush.
- Do it again.
- Hold on. Hold on.
If you don't get after
this, you will be shamed.
(buzzer dings)
- It's a packet of crisps.
- That's not fair!
- Packet of crisps.
- Crisps?! Whoa whoa whoa.
- It is a packet of crisps
- I say crisps, I say
crisps, I'm from England!
- She's from England. Crisps are chips.
- Your food is coming out.
Its coming out.
- I'm not allowed in public.
- Hold on, hold on, crisps?
- Chip, potato chip, we call them crisps.
I've been in London, I'm
sorry, its my country.
- I think cheating is " if
you don't get it with this"
crunch in your mouth.
Fine! Everybody wants
her on the damn wall.
- Don't shame me for being hungry
in the middle of an intense game.
- Here we go all right.
- You were so offended by crisps.
- Emily you're up.
- Five.
- Let's go.
- Damn.
- Wait, I see Blunt
trying to catch a
glimpse. No no no looking.
- All right. Here we go. Here we go.
- It sounds the same.
(buzzer dings)
- Brush?
(incorrect buzzer)
- What is up, do you have
a thing with brush, no.
- Are you okay?
- [Akbar] Did you brush your hair today?
- [Kelly] It sounds like a brush. Okay.
- Don't look!
- I can't see anything.
- I can't.
- We need a guess Emily.
- Say brush.
- You could think of something
that was invented in outer space, perhaps.
- What the hell are you doing!
- I just thought we were
supposed to be nice to the guest.
- I have no idea, I wouldn't even know.
Sounds like pebbles or something.
- Pebbles? What kind of pebbles are these?
- She doesn't know it,
don't give her the point.
- Go on, what is it? What is it?
What is that?
- It's called Velcro.
- Oh, that did not sound like Velcro.
- It sounds like a brush,
you know when you like-
- Velcro is like (imitates
velcro) - the rip.
- Ladies, we can't accept it.
The judges rulings are final.
And the score right now:
Emily two points.
Kelly, you have yet to get on the board.
But its your turn, its your turn.
We're getting a report here.
The judges have made a switch.
They're saying this one is worth 5 points.
- No no no.
- Yes!
- 5 points. Wait its actually
Kelly telling me this.
I'm hearing her voice.
- Exactly. Thank you so
much Matt, thank you Matt.
- Okay, choose your case.
- Okay. Oh, I choose the case?
1 because I am numero uno.
Except not with this, not with that brush.
- It would be so good.
- If its a brush, I'm gonna die.
Everything sounds like a brush.
- Ladies. Are you ready?
Five points at stake.
Whichever one gets this
will be our champion.
- Pebbles, brushes, pebbles, brushes.
(buzzer dings)
- Emily.
- Pebbles.
(incorrect ding)
- Pounding rocks.
Kelly, you need to get this correct.
- I want to hear again.
- [Emily] It's not a brush.
- okay. Once again, we
will get you the same.
- Oh, I know what it is.
Can I say what it is?
Can I go again?
- Is it like,
- can I go again?
- Can I hear it again?
- Please can I go again.
- Okay one second. No
you can't go again Emily.
- You have it in your mouth?
- Don't give her any more
clues 'cause I know what it is.
Don't do it.
- Here we go Kelly.
- No, no. She's heard
enough. Time for her guess.
- And you cannot guess Emily, twice.
Although we are hearing that right now?
- I hear like a piece of candy?
(correct buzzer) (screams)
- I knew it as well.
- Okay.
- Kelly Clarkson for the
first time in recorded history.
- [Emily] Its rigged.
Whole thing is rigged.
- I will not sleep tonight
if I accept this as a win.
- But Emily please help
yourself to the chips.
I will not accept this win.
I do not accept this win.
- Well, to be fair he
ate the potato chips,
he ate the potato chips.
- He did but still, Emily wins the game.
I'm a fair person, I'm a fair person.
All right, thank you guys for playing.
And you know what
screw y'all for not
having a brush, whatever.
You can see Emily in
A Quiet Place part two
in theaters May 28th and in Jungle Cruise
which I'm stoked about in
theaters later this summer.